[Music]
hello everyone
how are you today i'm great casey and i
just got back from filming just kidding
party
can you believe that jkp we're doing
just skinny party again but
only for patreon if you're interested in
seeing
jk party videos if you're a tiki party
fan make sure to check out the just
kidding news
patreon because it'll be right there it
was so much fun it was like we time
traveled like
five six years ago back when we used to
be filming in the office
david was there i don't know we had a
blast we even played mafia so if you're
a mafia fan
check that out it'll be coming soon i
don't know when exactly but maybe by the
time you guys are watching this it's
already there
i decided to turn on the camera and
start talking to you guys because
there have been a few things around the
house that i have been very
eager to share with you guys especially
me repotting
some plants so i don't know if i've
mentioned on this channel yet but
i am now a plant mom i'm a proud plant
mom
but i'm really trying to uh to keep
these plants alive damn
i'm like trying to really make sure that
they don't die on me because i've always
had
a brown thumb never ingrained them i've
been meaning to repot these plants
for a while because mama chan actually
went with me to the nursery and we
bought a whole bunch of plants
and i've been taking care of them
recently like ever since we got them
i've been watering them i've been trying
to
prune off like whatever leaf like
browning leaves that
are happening i don't know i'm really
new to this plant mom life so
if you guys have any advice please i am
more than willing to receive
advice i am completely lost but before
we get to the plants i recently went to
go
thrift shopping so i went to the thrift
store and i also went to homegoods and i
got a few things
that i absolutely love so i'm going to
show you right now first off
we finally mounted the tv thank you papa
chan he actually mounted it for us when
he was here
and so that's finally there so we ended
up moving that piece of furniture that
used to be here
i have a feeling i talked about this
already this is pretty much
a done diesel but i bought this pillow
at the thrift store
but the pillowcase isn't on so don't
think that that's the pillow i got i'm
actually gonna pull it out of the
dirty laundry just to show you what it
looks like but i have to wash it
and it looks like this it's this pattern
it's like a nice little
rosy pink and i saw it
and i loved it i think it was like three
books so i'm like hell yeah cause
pillows are expensive so if you want
pillows check out your local thrift
store
i recommend it i got that from the
thrift store
and then we got this box from home goods
because i just i felt like
this needed something else here and i
was planning on buying
another one of these but i realized
putting things in here especially if
it's going to be at the bottom door i
just don't like how you can see
inside of this basket so i was like no
no we're not doing that again
we're getting one that has a lid so i
got this guy
and then i also got all of these to fill
all of this space but i realized i
really do not like the whole dvd look so
this is our dvd collection
that we just could not let go of when we
were shedding
all this excess stuff that we just no
longer wanted casey and i we both
have an attachment to these dvds most of
mine are all
disney beauties and i think most of them
are here but then he has a lot of like
kung fu movies and charlie chaplin
movies that are collectibles
and just other movies that he really
loves that he's just like i can't let go
of these
so we ended up saving all these dvds and
so i thought it would be
like a good decorative kind of piece i
guess is just to display them but
after seeing them here i don't like it
so what i'm gonna do is i'm still gonna
leave them out but instead of having
them on the top shelf i'm gonna just
switch it out for these boxes
and then put the boxes on the top shelf
and then move the dvds down to the
bottom shelf
and just have it like that in the
meantime until i can figure out a better
dvd situation i know where you're
thinking you're like why don't you just
put the dvds inside the boxes and i
could do that
but if we want to pull out a dvd we're
going to have to sort through the boxes
maybe i can do it alphabetical order i
mean
i know there's solutions but as of right
now i'm like i don't like the idea of
putting the dvds in these boxes so i
don't know what i'm going to do
but as of now that's what i'm doing i'm
putting dvds on the bottom shelf
these boxes on the top shelf and that's
what we're doing okay and the reason why
i'm moving it to the top shelf is
because when i lay down
when i go to sleep this is my view
and i don't like that i don't like it i
just i don't
just don't like it so that's what we're
gonna do and then the other thing that i
did
is i brought this map from the office
which i'm actually i feel really weird
about this
but i actually gave this map to joe
i gifted it to him when i get it but you
know like i just i gave it to him i was
like oh yeah joe you want to scratch off
the map
here you go i have this extra map and so
i gave it to him because this map was
living
in casey's office at the other office
the downtown
office that we had for jk and then once
we moved everything over here
i just gave it to joe i was like yeah i
was just sitting there just take it so
he took it and then i saw this map
sitting at our current jk news office
and i was like hey joe
did you want that map he was like no
actually i have no use for it there's
nowhere i could put it
you can take it if you want and i was
like are you sure isn't that weird like
i gave it to you i feel weird
taking it back when i gave it to you and
he's like i don't even care like for
real just take it so i'm like okay so i
took it
and now it's hanging over our bed and
the other map that i had which was this
one i have this map here
on the floor i mean i'm thinking about
just hanging it here in the meantime
just to just do something with it
but for long term wise like i'm not i'm
not keeping that map there is way too
many maps in this room
so i don't like that um but anyway back
to
the thrift stuff i found this at the
thrift store and look it kind of matches
that tree in the background
yeah i found this and i'm like i really
like it so i don't know if you've
noticed but the theme of
this bedroom is more like how do i
describe it it's like um
1800 z beige neutral color
traveling and like indiana jones
traveling kind of
aesthetic is what i guess i'm trying to
go for if i had to give it
a name of some sort so this i saw this
at the
thrift store and i was like dude this
matches perfectly i just don't know
where to put it
so i don't know i'm thinking about where
to put this and since i only have one
it kind of bugs me if i would put it
like i was considering the fact that i
could just put it like
right here or maybe like right here but
it's so small and i only have one of
them and i need things to be
sort of symmetry or something but look
let's see how tiny it is
i don't know if you can see but i don't
know i'm thinking maybe i'll put it
there then that means i have to find
something for the other side
and i have nothing so i don't know in
the meantime it's been living right here
and the other thing i got was this look
at this
i bought this vase at the thrift store
and i bought this
table storage thing because look move
this
and then you can open it and it's ta-da
it's like a storage table thingy and i
got this one at home goods
so this came through home goods came
through and then these little plant
thingies
it's actually leftover leaves from my
valentine's day bouquet
so i have that there and i also have
these left over from valentine's
just living in the bathroom and then i
also have more
flowers that's like similar to that
downstairs
in the kitchen i really freaking love
this because i'm like
there's like this empty space here i
just didn't know what to do with
and when i saw that table at home goods
and that vase
at the thrift store i'm like but what i
need to do with this
is raise it higher because it's really
really low and the reason why
i ended up hanging it this low to begin
with is because
back when this used to be over here
there we also used to have the imac
right there
and so an early pandemic days i was
doing
zoom episodes big mood episodes for the
big movie podcast
and so this was my background right so
this is what
the zoom episode would see and so i was
like oh man that wall is so empty so i
just quickly put like a thumbtack and i
hung this
that low because that was that's what
was in frame but then now that i have
this table and that
buzz i need to raise it up so
i'm probably gonna do that or maybe i
might just find a different
artwork piece to put there and then move
this here
is what i was thinking i don't know
we'll see oh and then also i got these
trash cans look how freaking cute
i got these new trash cans so i used to
have these ikea
trash cans that were like they were
really really old
and really gross and it was just like
now we got to replace them
so i got one for my side and one for
casey's side so
i'm really loving that what else have i
gotten that you guys haven't seen
let's go through the house what else now
i just gotta do something with all these
white walls
there's so many white walls going down
the stairs
like what do we do with all this space
so much white walls
so much look at this it's like i'm in an
asylum but
eventually i'm planning on just getting
a whole bunch of picture frames and
making this an entire gallery wall but
man i really don't know when that's
gonna happen because i don't want to
hang up
all those frames i've actually been
considering
making my own frames now that i have a
miter saw back to the stuff that i added
to the house
look so i found this at home goods this
at home goods
that at home goods and this at the
thrift store
look at that do you like that i got this
idea from friends
because you know like on friends the
show they actually have an entire
picture frame over their
eye hole thingy peephole and then it
just complemented the rest of the gold
so well this doesn't really complement
the decor
but i got it in japan it's supposed to
protect the house
i got it in a kyoto so i don't know i
just leave it here oh yeah see look
it's a golden temple thingy yeah we went
to go see the golden temple
i think it was kyoto yeah i think it was
yeah i bought that there
so i just have it hanging here i
honestly do not know what it says so if
you know let me know in the comments
but yeah so ignoring that piece look at
how cool the door
looks now i really like that frame i i
actually spray painted it so it was
already a gold color
but i spray painted it be more gold
because the gold that it came with it
was kind of brownish
didn't really look right so i spray
painted that
and i added it to that and then up here
i was like dude something
needs to go here it's like it's way too
bare so i found that piece and i'm super
happy
with that i really liked it a lot and
then same thing with these guys
this one i mean i really like it but i
am considering
maybe staining this wood to be like a
slightly darker wood
maybe something that would match with
this or
one of those cutting boards back here so
i don't know i'm thinking about like
staining it so it could just kind of
match
because that's like the white wood it
looks good don't get me wrong i like it
it's just i don't know if it really
blends well with everything you know
what i mean same thing with this frame
here in this black
frame i'm like maybe
yeah i think i think it'll go this
mirror is black i bought that
black on purpose because i knew it was
going to go about this mirror so i'm
like maybe this isn't such a big
this is not that crazy because then
there's also like black and white
from these cushions and then if you go
over here
there's black and white triangles decals
that i put here a long time ago
maybe we just leave that black it's okay
maybe i'll paint this black i don't know
but anyway back to the new stuff
and then i found this cute ass
basket tray look at this i found this at
home goods too
i'm like oh my god i'm obsessed it's so
pretty and it said they they make it in
indonesia or something so
it's so pretty i liked it a lot and so
now it goes
right here so
that's kind of like the house stuff oh
there's one thing
so this is the other thing i got at the
thrift store
look at this it says home and then
there's
three hooks on it it was actually black
when i bought it
and the same time that i spray painted
that frame i spray painted this
gold but i i messed it up
so this is what i mean look at this you
see how bumpy
and gross it looks it is because
i was spray painting it inside of this
box and so when i was spray painting it
i was trying to make sure
that you know it's like whatever excess
gold
it stayed in the box right so i was like
spraying it spraying it
and i ended up spraying i guess too much
because it
it started like pulling up you kind of
tell like right here
it started pulling up so what i did
which i
don't necessarily recommend you do if
you decide to spray paint things
and it pulls up i decided to get my
finger
and just kind of like smooth it out and
it i mean it did
work it worked for the most part but i
got too greedy man
i just i got too perfectionist with it
once i start spreading it with my finger
it actually removes some of the paint
obviously so that you could see some of
the black peeking through again
and no i didn't sand it i know what
you're asking i know i should have
sanded it
i actually bought a sander too i should
have sanded it but i didn't and so
that's why the black was peeking through
and when i was smudging it with my
finger to make it smooth
it was working but then because i had to
like respray it again to cover up the
black it ended up
pulling up again and so i just kept like
spraying
and then like smoothing it with my
finger and then like spraying it
smoothing with my finger and then it
just
it ended up really bad so now that's why
it looks all texturized
so then because the h came out so
texturized and the o came out to
texturize but the m
came out so smooth i was trying to like
figure out how to texturize it and then
the m and the e
just ended up being way worse than this
so then i wiped it off with the napkin
and then the m actually came out pretty
good but then by then by the time i
started doing these guys i was already
so how do i put this
i was intoxicated with all the fumes
so i'm like i don't think my brain can
handle fixing the h and the o
so i was only able to fix the m and the
e and then i told myself because i'm
like i was just so
crazy off the fumes that i'm like you
know what i gotta let myself breathe
some like fresh air i need to focus
and i was like you know what maybe i'll
just sand it
and really make it nice and crisp
if it really bothers me because i'm like
you know what i
have it gold that's what i wanted it's
done
it's not perfect it's okay maybe i can
live with it but if i
if i see it every single day because i'm
planning on putting it right here
if i see it every single day and it
bothers me that the h and the o
are just so texturized and jacked up
then i'm just gonna redo this whole
thing i'll sand it do it right
prime it spray paint it maybe paint it i
don't know i'll do it right
but as of right now it's like maybe i
can live with it so i was lazy
and i left it all i have to do now is
hang it though that's the last step
i gotta hang it but yeah so
that's what we got going on around here
and honestly yeah like finding all these
these home thingies it just makes me so
happy
i don't know i like it but then i get
scared because i'm like oh
this is costing money because now which
brings me
to pots so i finally got some pots
here's some that i've opened already i
don't know about you but
i found it extremely difficult to find
proper pots that have drainage holes
and a saucer did you know that it's not
that common
do you know where to go find these guys
because at home depot and lowe's they
had like zero selection
i mean they do have selection but it's
just it's ugly it's not aesthetic right
it's not cute so i was able to find a
whole bunch of these guys on
amazon but they were so expensive oh my
god why you have to be so expensive
i think for two of these guys it was
like 46.99 or something for two
pots i'm like i'm way too cheap for this
but i was talking to casey and i'm like
you know what my plans are dying
i need some damn pots i just can't bring
myself to buy
disgustingly ugly pots so you know what
it's an investment
it's an investment guys it's an
investment
so i bought a whole bunch of these guys
and now i'm going to finish opening up
all these planters
and repot them and i'll show you my
plants outside we're outside now
i unpacked all of the pots that i
purchased
they're all right here there's actually
more pots
or planters or whatever you want to call
them come in it's just that they
haven't arrived yet but these are the
ones i'm working with so far
and that's okay because i don't think
i'm even gonna get to all of these
because i don't have
enough potting soil this is where i'm at
because when we bought this bag
mama chan she actually helped us out
with our boxwood
plant which are these guys so all of
these right here
so these and then all of those over
there she
repotted them or did she repot them yeah
i guess you could say that i don't know
she added more potting soil and she also
added this like uh mulch kind of thing
like this bark and she says that that
helps retain the moisture
of the water so we don't have to like
boxwood trees or whatever you call them
these bushes
they're super easy to keep alive because
clearly we've kept them alive
all these months ever since we got them
and so you they don't really need a lot
of water but
even so she was like oh if you put this
stuff on it then it'll retain moisture
and you don't have to water it as often
either so that's that's what we got
going on and that's the reason why a lot
of the potting mix
got used up so i'm probably not going to
get to all these plants but at least i
wanted to try to rescue some of them
because i'm like
poor babies you've been stuck in these
some of these plants look like my
primrose here
oh no my poor babe it's dying on me
already so these leaves were all weak
and
wilted and like two days ago
and that's because when i went filming
big mood i didn't water it
them that day i just left the house
totally didn't water them
even when i got back home i totally
forgot and then look they started
getting all like what the hell you
stupid lady you gotta you gotta give us
water we're thirsty and so i did
i gave them water yesterday like i
watered them and
these leaves started perking up and i
was like oh my gosh
you were just so thirsty i'm so sorry
with this stuff though i mean i don't
know this just came out from like one
day of not watering them
it's pretty crazy these primrose are
really really really thirsty
but yeah a lot of these have bloomed
already they're so pretty
look at all them but then these guys see
like this one right here is like dying
on me oh no
oh no i gotta rescue you guys so i did
end up putting this one in a different
pot so
they used to be in the this one used to
be in this pot but then i got this pot
from this plant so this one
i believe it's called an anthrim or
something like that
this actually i purchased during
christmas time and
completely neglected it i got two of
these guys so i actually had it indoors
and then i found out that it's poisonous
to the cats i'm like oh my gosh so then
i took it outdoors
and i read that they don't like direct
sunlight so i was like oh crap so then i
put them in the front of the house
and then we were gone for three weeks
never watered it
and i think it rained during the time we
were gone and so the pot that it was in
it was in this one which does have holes
but the uh it was like in a decorative
one that had no holes so it totally just
drowned this poor baby poor plant it was
drowning and it was getting root rot and
so
i ended up taking it out of this pot and
then putting it into this one which
actually
is it belongs to isaac's tree the fake
tree that he has in his room so i want
to give it back to him because it just
matches his room
so planning on repotting this guy into
one of these
new ones that's just forever going to
live there so i ended up trimming
a lot of the the dead leaves and
some of these leaves though you see this
stuff it used to be like way more
so i'm actually feeling good about this
plant because i feel like i'm saving
its life because this too like you guys
could see but
it just got so wrecked and it actually
had like two more flower buddies
that i just had to chop off because they
were just it was a lost cause
they were not gonna make it so i was
like well maybe i can at least rescue
this one
and maybe it'll bloom in the future
somehow
i am able to maintain it nice and
healthy
which like i said i don't know what i'm
doing but i'm doing my best
but yeah i got rid of all the old soil
that was just drowning all the roots and
it was so cool seeing the whole root
system
like whoa it's like veins it was pretty
cool
i should have vlogged that but i was
just like i was so into this i totally
forgot to bring out the camera
when i was doing that but i remembered
for this stuff for these other guys
we're doing it right now we're doing it
but anyway so i'm going to be
repotting that one and then over here i
have brussels sprouts
so i wanted to try to grow something
that we can eat and brussels sprouts are
my favorite and i saw them at the
nursery and i'm like oh
maybe i could try to grow them and then
mama tan was like girl don't even try
because you your backyard here this
space here
gets zero sunlight or not zero maybe
gets like about an
hour-ish a day of direct sunlight
and brussels sprouts like the cabbage
family they
need a lot of sunlight and so i was like
well
maybe i don't know somehow i think maybe
i can make it work
somehow she was like they're gonna die
on you but go for it just try at least
you can get some experience so i don't
know i got them
and then yesterday i looked at these
guys i was like wait what's happening
there's so many holes
on these leaves there weren't any holes
on the leaves before what happened
and then i took a good look in here and
i found out it was infested with aphids
i think that's how you say it but these
tiny little bugs
and they were so many bugs in
inside of all of these things so i have
six of them
all six of these guys had so many bugs
in them and they look like
tiny little gray eggs and it was so
gross
and i even saw a tiny little caterpillar
just like
roaming around in there i immediately
googled i'm like oh my god how do i get
these bugs out of these plants it's so
gross
i'm gonna eventually eat these guys
that's nasty and so
i found out that you just directly spray
them with the water hose like
blast them with water hose they they'll
just blast off and
you get them off and that's good but it
was such an intense infestation that i
also did
this thing that they recommended which
was i got my little spray bottle
and i mixed water with dish soap and so
i sprayed the heck out of these after i
already like
used the water hose and i tried getting
most of them off whatever like if there
were any in here hiding
i killed them off with the dish soap in
the water and
i checked today and they look great i
don't see a single bug so i
hope i got the problem controlled
see look you see that wait
that right there that is an aphid
we gotta kill this sucker before he
spreads wait is it
i think it's not no it is it totally is
you
yuck fling it bye
for my brussels sprouts i read
that they suggest to put them in 12
inch pots do you know how freaking huge
those are and how hard they are to
freaking find
i'm like no no no no no we're not doing
12-inch pot so i have
six of these guys in here so i'm like
you know what we're just doing four-inch
pots okay because that's all i could
find so we're doing four-inch pots for
these and you guys let me know in the
comments
am i insane and that will i not get any
brussels sprouts
out of these guys if they're so
constricted into these tiny little pots
you're probably right but
like i said they're just an experienced
learning experience
kind of plan but honestly if you guys
have advice
let me know i need advice tell me tell
me what to do tell me if i'm doing
things wrong
because i really want to know and i want
to get better even though i'm already
saying i know i'm doing this wrong
already if i'm
getting really tiny pots but they're so
expensive okay
i'm trying to find good ones but anyway
moving on so i do have these bigger pots
right you're
thinking like tip why not just put on
these huge ass pots because those are
for these other plants okay
these need love too so we're gonna see
if i could get anything out of these
tiny little orange pots
these brussels sprouts we'll see we'll
see moving on to the next plant this is
a croton
i think is how you pronounce it i just
read these words i didn't hear people
say that so if i'm pronouncing them
wrong let me know but yeah it's a croton
plant
i thought it was really pretty at the
nursery i'm like oh i like the colors
and so
we're repotting this guy i mean this pot
isn't that ugly it's actually kind of
cute but i didn't want any white pots
because i already have white
countertops so repotting that i bought
two
of these mona lavender aka
flex
[Music]
that's what they're called that's the
scientific name for these plants
but this is what i'm talking about it
looks like this there we go
it flowers these kind of flowers so
there's
one tiny one right here so this is the
kind of flowers that this plant should
bloom
and i got two of these guys because i
thought they were so pretty and then
mama was like oh yeah you don't want to
get plants that have already bloomed
because then
they've already reached their peak and
the only way
to go is downhill so she was like yeah
just get ones that haven't bloomed yet
so then that's why i got these guys they
haven't bloomed yet same
goes for this plant so this is a
heliotrope
and it's supposed to flower these like
bluish purple kind of flowers
i have not seen a single bud yet so
we'll see how that goes
but this plant actually comes with
a spider you see that mrs spider right
there
she made herself a nice little home and
honestly i don't know anything about
spiders
so the only spider that i do know is a
black widow i can't see the belly to
confirm whether or not the black widow
but i have a feeling it's not a black
widow but you guys let me know
i noticed lady spider maybe about a week
and a half ago
and every day i'm like she's still there
and she's still there she's living there
i don't want to disturb her and then one
time i was kind of like poking her to
see if she could turn around i could see
her belly to
see if it's black widow or not and then
she reacted and i freaked the hell out
so i'm like
i'm not messing with you okay lady you
just you make yourself a nice little
home right there i'm not gonna mess with
you
yeah that's the heliotrope moving on is
i got these two snake plants so this is
one of them
and this is just like that typical like
if you have a brown thumb there's no way
you're gonna kill these guys so i'm like
okay i need some safe ones because i
want to feel good about myself
so i got one of these snake plants and
then
this is the other one the silver snake
plant i do have a question though and
then i couldn't find this
on google so you let me know what do you
think is this normal is this little spot
here normal yeah like this spot right
here is that normal because
these guys i'm like well i see other
stem thingies leaves that have these so
i'm not too worried about this one but
this one
is this like a normal thing for a snake
plant to have
i don't know let me know because look
there's another thing here too oh my god
i feel like this is probably maybe okay
i don't know
i don't know these things because yeah
look see this one has these streaks too
i'm like i feel like that's okay but i
don't know maybe it's not
okay but like they're not gonna die on
me but if you guys have any
suggestions as to what to do to get rid
of these
and make my plant healthier please let
me know i would love it i would
appreciate it for the finale
is my calla lily i got a keller lily
this little lady she's so pretty
and she already sprouted some new leaves
or not leaves but i guess they're going
to become leaves where are they these
thingies this camera won't focus but
there's like a little curly little leaf
right here
and she's making lots of them and i hope
to see a flower one day
but you guys let me know if you know
anything about cali lilies what is
happening to this plant what is going on
here
what is this what's happening here i was
and then also this one like there's like
these weird like vein scratches
and i was trying to look up like
problems with kel and then this spot
right here is new i didn't notice this
so i'm like what's happening what's
going on with this little lady her
leaves are starting to curl up a little
bit
and she did not look like this so my
guess
is that it's probably because she needs
a bigger pot what are you doing with me
lady
you need to let me grow i can't grow so
i'm gonna
die that's my guess let me know if i'm
right or if i'm wrong you guys have your
own guesses please i need help i don't
know how to take care of this
i don't know how to i don't know i don't
know what's happening i definitely know
i need to water her which i'm gonna be
doing
her soil is very dry right now i did
water her
two days ago but all of a sudden she's
very very dry so me that could also be a
very obvious factor is that she's just
thirsty then i'm also
afraid of over watering i don't want to
over water these plants so
i don't know i'm just winging it okay
anyway let's get to
ripatti
all right so i did my very first one
which was the snake plant
and i messed up because immediately i
took it out of the pot and i just placed
it on this tray and i was like oh wait i
need to get the pot ready so i had to
put soil
on the bottom of the pot and my first
one i was already like
i'm messing this up i should have looked
up a youtube video on how to do this
or done my research somehow but in
typical to fashion i'm just winging it
yeah i don't know i hope i'm doing a
good thing but yeah i added soil at the
bottom
and then i placed the plant inside the
pot and then i put more soil at the top
and then now i'm about to put some
fertilizer that mama chan recommended
you guys let me know
if this fertilizer is a bad idea for
all of these plants because it says all
purpose i just i like easy things okay
if it's a bad thing let me know and i'll
stop
using them for my plants so i'm gonna
put some fertilizer on the top and then
top it off with more soil and then water
it
and call it a day with the snake blend
move on to the next one oh yeah i forgot
to mention
you guys like my watering cans so huge
but when i received this i thought it
was the funniest thing it's like
comically gigantic but it's also
super cute because it looks like an
upside down diamond ring
which i really liked but it's gigantic
this is two gallons here
ah i didn't know what two gallons really
look like i guess
but it's freaking gigantic so i was
actually considering returning it and
getting a smaller one but then casey is
like
nah keep it i mean you like it i mean
and then also yeah you get to
just put less water or like less trips
to
uh fill up you know so i'm like all
right fine i'll keep it but
it's so huge i just think it's so funny
how gigantic it is
cool look i took out the crouton from
its pots and you can see all the roots
that is
so cool look at this that this is its
lifeline right here
all of these are okay i gotta stop
recording i gotta i gotta put it back in
soil okay
sorry bye
so i have now moved three plants
to three pots and i'm left with kind of
a dilemma-ish a little bit
so these pots are so these ones are four
inch
these are six inch and these are eight
inch
and i am kind of conflicted on
what which plants to put where so i put
those plants in those pods because
the croton i put onto six inch because
the pot it came in was already smaller
than it so i'm thinking
like well they need room to grow so they
need to be in
bigger pots than what they're currently
at so that's why i moved
these guys over to the six inch and then
i moved the
calla lily to the eight inch but i have
a feeling i'm gonna have to repot it and
put it into a 10 inch if i can find one
but as of now i have all of these right
and so
for these other ones i have
one two three four i have four plants
that are still in one gallon
pot and i'm like dang should i put them
in the six
inch or will that be too small because
as of now like yeah
just i feel like it'll just be too small
so look here's a six inch pot this is a
one gallon thingy so it's like
pretty much the exact same size except
the one that it came with it's already
deeper so i feel like if i would move
this plant to this pot i'd be doing it a
disservice
but the thing is i ordered way too many
six inch pots
and like i said it's really difficult to
find bigger pots
that have a hole and that have a saucer
so
these guys it came with like this little
mesh thing to put inside the pot and
then it has
a single hole it came with a saucer
that's why i was like
i mean i guess i'll get these but
they're just so expensive and then also
i mean there are other bigger pots but
they don't come with saucers
a lot of pots that i've been looking at
do not have holes
they just don't have drainage holes like
i actually forgot to show you guys but i
bought
these two other pots and i decided to
just use them for decoration inside the
house because they have zero holes
and like that that whole trip to the
thrift store and home
goods i went to those places with the
intent
of buying pots for these plants outside
but i didn't end up getting that i ended
up getting all this other decor
which ended up working out anyway but
look this is one of the pots that i got
so i decided to put this fake snake
plant that i have here
inside of this pot but see
all these decorative pots they just
don't have any holes
they just don't come with holes so
couldn't use this for the outside but
it's kind of cute it has little legs and
then this other one over here
now this one was tricky because this pot
also
no holes but it also had this really
thick lip
that i couldn't get any other fake
plants that i have around the house to
fit into this pot except for this one so
this one's super cute but it has to be
hidden back here next to the kitty poop
because that was the only plant that
could actually fit inside that pot but
like i said i can't find any damn pots
that are cute that have holes and that
have saucers it's just
impossible man but i mean the ones that
i did
find confusing like i said it's just
really difficult
there's just not enough bigger pot so
anyway back to these pots
the thing is they came in a set so all
these pots that i have here they all
came in a set of
two so it's either i purchased an eight
inch
with a six inch or i purchased a six
inch with a four inch and so that's why
i ended up
with a whole bunch of six inch pots so
i'm like i don't know what do i do
is it do you think my plant will die if
i leave it in the same size
pot like i feel like it's kind of kind
of a bad idea to put it in the same size
pot like shouldn't they have room to
breathe and grow i don't know
i'm conflicted guys so i feel like at
this point i'm just gonna stop and do a
little research i'm gonna call
mama tan see what she suggests and also
i'm gonna ask her if i should put
mulch on these plants too to keep them
nice and moist
i'm gonna consult her with her about
these plots i would love
to read your guys's comments on this
video
let me know your thoughts what do you
think what should i do
i'm gonna try to find some more research
to try to be a little bit more educated
in this whole plant world
but man these plants like it's
intimidating trying to have like keep
plants alive like this is life in my
fingertips you know when i
when i was showing you guys those roots
i was like oh my god the whole life
system is right here and that's what i
freaked out and i was like
wait what am i doing recording let me
put it away and let me give it some like
potting soil breathing life because i'm
like i don't want it to die on me
this whole plant heaven life is a little
stressful but i enjoy it i really like
the challenge
and i'm just worried about doing
something wrong and killing my plants
i just don't want to kill them and i
also want to get more i want to fill
this entire counter space
with plants like all of this stuff right
here i would love to just fill it up
with
green because i already have a lot of
fake green here a lot of fake green
inside the house and i just want actual
real life life
on this these counter tops here so yeah
i don't know like i just
i like to fill it up with some green
right
make it feel breathe in here thanks for
watching guys
looking forward to reading your comments
i love you see you next time
[Music]
bye
[Music]